- [Notorious B.I.G.] Yo!
Check it out, straight from Brooklyn!
Don't be a stupid rapper,
because a stupid rapper is a ....
that has somebody else
tell them what to do.
Whatever you're going to
do, just do it for a reason
don't be the fool that
just sits back and do
because somebody else is doing it.
I wanted to get in the
game and get the big house
and the cars with the pool,
I wanted to do all that.
And that's one of the bad things
about the game is, when you get launched,
even your friends will
turn against you man.
- He consistently ranks
as one of the greatest
and most influential rappers of all time.
When he released his debut album
"Ready to Die" in 1994,
he became a central figure
in the East Coast hip-hop scene.
He has certified sales of 17 million units
in the United States.
He's the Notorious B.I.G.
and here is my take
on his Top 10 Rules for Success.
Rule number two is my personal favorite,
and I'm curious to figure out which one
you guys like the best, and as always,
if he's saying something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
Enjoy!
(inspiring upbeat music)
- Take control of your
Don't be the type of rapper,
don't be a stupid rapper.
A stupid rapper is a ....
that has somebody else
tell them what to do,
which is not always wrong,
but if it's something
that you feel that you don't have to do,
you really have to question it
and find out why they want you to do it.
Most niggas, they feel like, well,
you see what Biggie's doing,
you know, he have the hat,
the Kangol, and listen,
you have to be like that.
But if you don't really
want to be like that,
you don't have to be like
that, you know what I'm saying?
A lot of .... try to tell
a nigga to do something
so quick
and give em examples of a ....
that did it and blew up
and make them think that
they can do the same thing,
which is not always necessarily true.
Whatever you going to do,
just do it for a reason.
Don't be the fool
that just sits back and do it
cause somebody else is doing it,
because the only thing they going to do
is follow somebody else's footsteps
and you're just going to be a shadow,
who would be a shadow for
the rest of their life
you know what I'm saying?
If you got a little something
that you know how to do,
progress at it, keep trying,
you know God knows what could happen,
you know what I'm saying,
you know that's what I do.
Just kept on rappin',
just happened to get to the right ears,
you know what I'm sayin'?
Man, I was just trying to do my thing man.
I kind of knew what I didn't want to do,
I didn't want to be that
ghetto corner rapper.
You know, when I had my
dreams of gettin' in the game,
it wasn't just to get in the game
and still be on the corner like, you know.
I wanted to get in the game
and get the big house and
the cars with the pool.
I wanted to do all that, you know,
and I know in order to do all that
there's certain things that you have to do
that just, a way you can pinch it off
and just add your flavor to it.
Me linkin' up with Puff, the old familiar,
old tracks, you know what I'm sayin',
that's going to get the adult attention,
you know what I'm sayin'.
It's just the lyrics
is going to get the younger
dudes' attention, so
we blend them both.
I mean hey,
if they want to wear the Versace
and the cool jeans and the Kangols
and "Yeah Biggie Biggie,"
it's all good with me
I ain't got no problem with it.
- [Narrator] Being a cat from Brooklyn
and just being on the corner
and being able to just
spit something real quick
and just murder that
whole circle, you know
that's where you get your
stripes and your stars.
♫ Yes it's me, the B.I.G.
♫ Competition ripper ever since 13
♫ Used to steal clothes
I was considered a thief
♫ Until I started
hustlin' on Fulton Street
♫ Makin' loot, knockin'
boots on the regular
♫ Pass the microphone I'm
the perfect competitor
♫ Jewels and all that,
my clothes is all that
♫ Chumps steppin' to me, that's
where they took a fall at
♫ B.I.G. without burner, that's unheard of
♫ I stay close to mine like Tina on Turner
♫ Quick to smother, a punk
♫ Undercover, word to mother, I'm above ya
♫ And I love ya, cause
you're a sweet bitch
♫ A crazy crab, that
might make my dick itch
♫ I flow looser than
Luther, words ya get used at
♫ B.I.G. is a born trooper
♫ Like ice cream I scoop ya, my
music you want to get loose at
♫ Stay pimp, and I'm not a booster
♫ So what'cha got to say?
This mackin' word is bond
♫ There's no other
assumption, I got it going on
♫ I'm not conceited,
my friends tell me this
♫ Even my mother, be
noddin' her head to this
♫ Makes her proud to
see her one son get loud
♫ Flip on a sucker, and bow to the crowd
♫ Drink a little Hennessy,
♫ Smoke a blunt or two or three or four
♫ Live in action,
guaranteed raw you dumb ass
- [Puff] Read the plaque.
- [Biggie] Read the plaque for the people
- [Puffy] Represent.
We get the plaques man.
Ready to die, double platinum.
Aight?
- We just, we going to keep
trying to feed our families
you know what I'm sayin', it's a job,
it ain't nothin' where somebody just felt
like doing or they didn't,
you know what I'm sayin'.
We was hungry.
Everybody got to eat.
I found something I was good at,
I'm just trying to flip it, keep it going.
I ain't trying to slack at all.
Just representing my peoples, my borough,
and my family and I'm aight.
I'm just trying to be that straight dude,
I done went through so much you know,
being in the streets or whatever
I done been through so much,
my mom's done been through so much.
It feels good to just have her at ease
you know what I'm sayin' you know,
her son is cool and keen in the streets
doin' no wrong and
tryin' to make it happen.
I got to stay on the positive vibe,
all my people's got to stay on
the positive vibe, you know?
The negativity just
brings failure, you know?
And we ain't trying to fail in this game,
we trying to succeed.
- [Interviewer] Is your family
the most important thing for you?
- Yeah, at this time right now yeah.
I mean I ain't going to lie, at one point
the music was more important
because I knew
that if I did good in the music
I could take care of
my family a lot better.
So I was more pushing towards
making sure the music was tight,
making sure every show I did was right
and just trying to get
as much money as I could
so I could take care of my family.
Now that the job is
basically done, I can chill.
My wife's album is about to come out
in maybe a month or two,
so I can just chill and just watch her,
you know just chill with her.
♫ To all the ladies in the
place with style and grace
♫ Allow me to lace these
lyrical douches, in your bushes
♫ Who rock grooves and make
moves with all the mommies
♫ The back of the club, sippin' Moet,
♫ is where you'll find me
♫ The back of the club, mackin'
hoes, my crew's behind me
♫ Mad question askin', blunt
passin', music blastin'
To me, I like the live stuff
better than the stuff on the album
'cause the stuff on the
album seems more relaxed.
You got to have a certain
tone, you know what I'm sayin.
Puff baby like don't get too excited
just chill, let it flow.
But when you on stage, sweat pouring down
I'm a big one too, sweat be drenching.
I just be representin',
you know what I'm sayin'?
Just doing my thing.
(rapping in background)
- When I first heard B.I.G.'s demo
the first few bars of B.I.G's demo
I felt the second coming
of Big Daddy Kane.
(rapping)
- From the first time I
heard Notorious B.I.G.
was from a demo tape
that I got from Mattie C
from The Source Magazine and I called him,
and I told him I was
looking for some new talent
I wanted something real, real raw.
And he said, "It's crazy, but I have
"something that's incredible."
- The first time that I heard B.I.G.
was on a Super Cat
record with him and Puff.
It was dope to me, 'cause
you know what I'm sayin'
I like Super Cat and you know
I ain't never heard cuz get at it before
so it was like a different
voice, a different sound
but it was fly to me
once I seen the video.
Seeing what he looks
like, our eyes approach
but I was like, yeah he sharp, he slick.
He'd be a rapper that I
would like to get to know,
you know what I'm talking about?
- I mean what B.I.G. did was he simplified
the most intelligent things,
he put them in layman's terms
that people would understand.
B.I.G. was definitely
like the Professor of
how it should be done.
And if you a student of rap
you got to listen to him.
And as you could hear
it in everybody's music
everybody's been citing Biggie's rhymes.
Me, everybody.
- He say whatever he wants to say and
it's put together so well you know, like
What'd he say, "You can
consider my career like Mike's,
anyone, Tyson, Jordan,
Jackson, Action, Pac--
(beep)
Ridiculous, you know
what I'm sayin like that?
That kind of (beep) like this,
for rappers that do (beep) like that
and come up with that
kind of thought provoking
word play is far and few between.
- I never seen him jot anything down.
I've never seen him.
When the sample was looped up,
he was just sitting down there like
Had his eyes closed,
he'd do this nasty thing
with his ear like
(puckering)
and then he'd just start spittin'
and I was like, "Holy (beep).
"That's sort of magic."
- [Interviewer] You open
every show with Warning,
one of your big songs right now.
How much are you exaggerating
which you now, rapper
of people coming to get you?
- I ain't exaggerating at
all man, that's real son.
That's real yo.
I ain't exaggerating at all man.
The mo' money you make,
the mo' problems you get.
And jealousy and envy
is just something that
comes with the territory man.
A lot of people with just negative energy.
Like my man Puff say,
it just surrounds you
and it makes you depressed, you know?
So, I got a rap about it,
and that's one of the bad
things about the game is
when you get launched,
even your friends will
turn against you man.
So I made a song about it.
- [Interviewer] But I
mean how real is your fear
that people constantly
comin' and want to shoot you.
- I mean, that's real.
I mean, I think about that every day.
Every day it's real.
That's how real it is.
I think somebody is trying to kill me.
I be waking up paranoid,
I be really scared.
I just be paro.
That's just the way I am.
You know,
you be seeing me scared to death.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Derek Taylor asked me to,
so if there is a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know what did he say
that had the biggest impact on you,
on your business, on your life.
What changes are you going to make
after watching this video?
Please leave in the comments below
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I wanted to
give a quick shout-out
to Jon D. Webster, Jon, thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book
and making that awesome
YouTube video about it.
I really, really, really appreciate it.
- Evan inspired me to write my sixth book
which is a self help book,
seriously love that guy.
- So thank you guys again for watching
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to believe
in yourself and remember,
Your one word is
Much love, I'll see you soon!